so here's the hypothesis when we talk
about color
we are actually talking about three
separate but related and overlapping
things
so first is color that happens without
us the tree falls in the forest it's
green even if we're not there
to see it tumble that's physics
chemistry the oscillation of
electromagnetic fields moving in a
direction
electromagnetic energy streaming from
the sun hitting earth's atmosphere
interacting hitting other surfaces and
particles
light 1.21 sextillion photons
hitting every square meter of earth's
sunlit surface every second
color is something that we make colored
things by dent of our hands and our
effort and our cognitive abilities
roman purple egyptian blue move colors
that didn't
exist on earth or anywhere in the
universe i mean you know
maybe until human ingenuity makes use of
all that physics and chemistry to make
them happen
usually we call these things pigments
these are things that absorb some colors
of light and reflect others presenting a
color to our eyes
the image that you see there are jugs
full of quantum dots eventually those
are going to be part of led tvs
it's arguably one of the most advanced
way people make colors today
and third there's the color that our
eyes and brands manufacture from those
other two things
light all around us bounces off or
through or among
surfaces into our eyeballs where
hideously complicated biological sensors
transduce
photons into neuroelectrical signals
the image that you see now is uh ramoni
kahal's hand-drawn map of a mammal's
retina
that comb looking part up at the top are
the rods and cones
those are the photoreceptors the back of
the retina that
perceive light and color